là tu vas passer du rêve au cauchemar
puisque tu vas devoir faire un duo
maintenant avec m m e gilles tu vas nous
faire un duo sur un titre que j'adore
game over qui a cartonné
c'était encore en 2013 ouais c'était à
2000 2013 c'est ça attendez vous c'est
parti attention musique on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j
[Applaudissements]
comme toi ponte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne joue pas
[Musique]
il attend beaucoup
j'suis pas alors l'horreur
donc là le flou c'est zéro par contre
personne se retourne moi ça la dernière
face à votre guise et les mettre aux
dîmes seront visités si nous regardent
lettres guinée sur la tête de ma mère
il doit se dire mais schlund non mais
franchement temps jeu là dans mes frères
oui tu sais alors en revanche je trouve
que ça te va très bien comme ça je peux
regarder en fait s'en sont tous et baila
d'un certain génie mais grave été cent
fois mieux comme asper de m'habiller
comme ça m'intéresse comme ça ce soir si
base il reste comme ça et si j'ai
toujours les baskets le jean est tout
aussi très frais fréron tu rentres à la
maison quand rafa toutefois qu'on n'a
pas le bac ou celle qui joue pas
appelle-moi pas coutume la passe appel
mardi à la demande afin tous elle te
kiffe comme ça et lita deux titres
conquis fait le plus là il ya six mois
c'était je te le donne
com
à séparer les autres a fait rentrer
slimane la note slimane amiens
la faille la passion
vous n'êtes pas content et bâle iii
[Musique]
on a jusqu'à le commandant cousteau pour
thalassa c'est juste à droite mais ça
c'est slimane saint-usuge à calypso
mais quel rapport sur la tête de ma mère
qui croyait aller pêcher la sardine ou
quoi mais faire sans déconner rien à
voir merci isabelle à l'est